you don't see a lot of green i love it
all right we got the scripts
so we're gonna have some fun here by the
way we can edit it so if we want to do
it again
we can to make it really good because
maria likes that so this is the
read-through
this is the read-through uh ryan here
who you can't see is gonna read for the
pedestrian and i'll just read batman i
guess i don't have a script
oh you don't all you have to do is once
when uh
batman says where did you get that
switch where did you get that sweater
you just say marshall's oh mike look at
you we got to get you a video agent
yeah i i need voiceover work i'm saying
all right
the justice league hits the sherman oaks
mall
i wrote this in five minutes batman
needs a sweater
martian manhunter john johns hates them
all flash loves it green lantern also a
mall enthusiast and lover of mint
chocolate chip ice cream
wonder woman is annoyed with the flash
as usual hot girl is just feeling sassy
and is always full of knowledge superman
has a date with lois lane later and
trying to cover it up he's also in a
hurry
so interior sherman oaks mall
day why are we at the mall because
batman needs a sweater
yep them bat nips are poking through his
costume again
quiet flash let's do it again that
sucked i could do it better it'll be
faster uh yeah i forgot that i was
batman i was like who's reading batman
all right do you want me to do it mike
yeah you want to read batman
yeah you're talking to yourself it
doesn't make it yeah you read batman
you'll be batman
all right here we go interior sherman
oak small
day because batman needs a sweater
yep and bat nips are poking through his
costume again
quiet flash and stop staring at my
nipples i hate them
all you can't get any lower than
being at the mall
i like them all they have been in
jerry's here i bet you they have my
favorite mint chocolate chip
yes okay can we please get this sweater
and get out of here
wow someone hates them all more than i
do
superman do you have a hot date you're
not telling us about
no why you said something flash not me
i didn't say a word about you and lois
hooking up can't tell you anything
flash how many women have you hit on in
this small
oh wonder woman someone jealous
gross please no be quiet
batman sees a pedestrian wearing a
really nice sweater he walks up to him
the pedestrian is a little startled
where did you get that sweater marshalls
crap
this mall doesn't have a marshalls but
there is a martian manhunter here
god you guys get it marshall's martian
that wasn't funny oh he's never funny
can we please just leave them all
hot girl checks her watch for an alert
well you're in luck soups
brainiac was just spotted attacking the
culver city mall
well can we at least stop by ben and
jerry's real quick i would
really love some mint chocolates
yes as they all walk off superman pouts
another maul ugh lois is going to kill
me
i didn't say anything quiet perfect
ladies and gentlemen that was really fun